what we're going to do in this video is
talk about a special class of random
variables known as binomial
variables and as we will see as we build
up our understanding of them not only
are they interesting in their own right
but there's a lot of very powerful
probability and statistics that we can
do based on our understanding of
binomial variables
so to make things concrete as quickly as
possible i'll start with a very tangible
example of a binomial variable and then
we'll think a little bit more abstractly
about what makes it binomial
so let's say that i have a coin so this
is my coin here it doesn't even have to
be a fair coin
let me just draw this really fast so
that's my coin and let's say on a given
flip of that coin the probability that i
get heads is 0.6
and the probability that i get tails
well would be 1 minus 0.6 or 0.4
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
define a random variable x
as being equal to the number
of heads
after
flips
of
my coin
now what makes this a binomial variable
well one of the first conditions that's
often given for a binomial variable is
that it's made up of a finite number of
independent trials
so
it's made up
made up
of
independent
trials now what do i mean by independent
trials
well a trial is each flip of my coin so
a flip
is equal to a trial in the language of
this statement that i just made
and what do i mean by each flip or each
trial being independent
well the probability of whether i get
heads or tails on each flip are
independent of whether i just got heads
and heads or tails on some previous lip
so in this case we are made up of
independent trials
now another condition is each trial can
be clearly classified as either a
success or failure or another way of
thinking about it each trial clearly has
one of two discrete outcomes
so each
trial and in the example i'm giving the
flip as a trial
can
be classified
classified
as
either
success
or
failure
so in the context of this random
variable x we could define heads as a
success because that's what we are
happening to count up and so you're
either going to have success or failure
you're either going to have heads or
tails on each of these trials
now another condition for being a
binomial variable is that you have a
fixed number of trials fixed
number
of
trials
so in this case we're saying that we
have 10 trials 10 flips of our coin
and then the last condition
is the probability
of success
in this context successes of heads
on each trial
each trial is constant
and we've already talked about it on
each trial on each flip the probability
of heads is going to stay at
0.6 if for some reason that were to
change from trial to trial maybe if you
were to swap the coin and that each coin
had a different probability then this
would no longer be a binomial variable
and so you might say okay that's
reasonable i get why this is a binomial
variable can you give me an example of
something that is not a binomial
variable
well let's say that i were to define the
y
and it's equal to
the number
of kings
after
taking
two cards
from
a standard deck of cards
the standard
deck
without replacement without
replacement
so you might immediately say well this
feels like it could be binomial we have
each trial can be classified as either
success or failure for each trials when
i take a card out if i get a king that
looks like that would be a success if i
don't get a king that would be a failure
so it seems to meet that right over
there
it has a fixed number of trials i'm
taking two cards out of the deck so it
seems to meet that
but what about these conditions that
it's made up of independent trials or
that the probability of success on each
trial is constant
well
if i get a king the probability of king
on the first trial probability of say
king
on
first
trial
would be equal to well out of a deck of
52 cards you're going to have four kings
in it so the probability of a king on
the first trial would be 4 out of 52
but what about the probability of
getting a king on the second
on the second
trial what would this be equal to well
it depends on what happened on the first
trial if the first trial you had a king
well then you would have so let's see
this would be the situation
given first trial
first king
well now there would be three kings left
in a deck of 51 cards but if you did not
get a king on the first trial now you
have four kings in a deck of 51 cards
because remember we're doing it without
replacement you're just taking that
first card whatever you did and you're
taking it aside
so what's interesting here is this is
not made up of independent trials it
does not meet this condition the
probability on your second trial is
dependent on what happens on your first
trial and another way to think about it
is because we aren't replacing each card
that we're picking the probability of
success on each trial also is not
constant
and so that's why this right over here
is not a
binomial variable
now if y if we got rid of
if without replacement and if we said we
did replace every card after we picked
it then things would be different then
we actually would be looking at a
binomial variable so instead of without
replacement if i just said with
replacement well then your probability
of a king on each trial is going to be 4
out of 52 you have a finite number of
trials your probability of success is
going to stay constant and they would be
independent and obviously each trial
could easily be classified as either a
success or a failure